salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique ça fait un certain
temps que je voulais vous faire une
vidéo sur un livre de michel houellebecq
qui est sorti en 2015 et qui avait fait
un petit peu polémique à l'époque
notamment il avait été accusé
d'islamophobie
et donc comme eh bien ces temps-ci
justement houellebecq sera un nouveau
livre anéantir je me disais bien quitter
c'était l'occasion de vous faire cette
vidéo alors tout d'abord je ne suis pas
du tout un spécialiste de houellebecq je
n'ai pas lu je n'ai pas lu d'autres
livres que soumission d'ailleurs
soumission gêne je ne les ai pas lu je
les écoutais en livre audio et donc tout
ce que je connais de l'auteur par cet
ouvrage est bien se base sur ce qu'on
lit dans les journaux ou sur internet et
sur les polémiques donc notamment sur
l'islamophobie supposé de ce livre
soumission et également sur les
questions et à deux de misogynie dont
houellebecq serait serait coutumier dans
ses ouvrages et donc aujourd'hui je vous
propose d vient de faire une analyse de
vous donner mon avis justement sur ce
roman est notamment sur la question est
bien de l'islamophobie mais aussi
d'avoir une grille lecture un petit peu
politique de cet ouvrage au delà de
cette question
alors soumission est donc un livre qui à
sa sortie a fait polémique sur les
questions ni islamophobie et qui nous
présente un monde la situation se passe
en 2022 ou un président
nouveau être élu et ce président est
musulman et donc va transformer la
france en république islamique manque de
chance pour houellebecq soumission est
sorti le jour même des attentats de
charlie hebdo ce qui a renforcé un petit
peu le côté polémique du livre
et a fait que la promotion est un petit
peu passés à la trappe alors tout
d'abord pour ceux qui n'auraient pas lu
le livre je vais vous faire un résumé et
puis après on verra le côté littéraire
et puis une analyse politique donc
soumission d'ailleurs soumission l une
des traductions possibles du mot islam
soumission se passe en france en 2022 le
contexte politique et que en 2017 et
bien françois hollande a été réélu pour
un deuxième mandat donc on n'est déjà
pas loin d'une dystopie ou d'un monde
post apo un quelque part
et bien il se trouve que le deuxième
tour de 2022 lui oppose marine le pen à
mohamed ben abaisse le président d'un
parti musulman qui s'appelle la
fraternité musulmane
également nous apprend au début du livre
qu'il ya tout un contexte est no
culturel très tendue qu'on n'est pas
très loin d'une guerre civile puisque
par moments il ya des émeutes on voit
des policiers des militaires armés qui
circulent on nous dit d'ailleurs qu'il
ya parfois des émeutes dans les
banlieues mais ce sont toujours ces
toujours l'extrême droite en fait qui a
provoqué qui a déclenché les émeutes et
donc on est à ce moment là on met 2022
et on découvre notre protagoniste notre
héros qui s'appelle françois qui est
prof de fac à la sorbonne à paris et qui
est prof de fac en littérature et qui
est spécialiste qui a fait sa thèse sur
huysmans un auteur du 19e et du 20e
siècle et donc on nous présente au début
de l'ouvragé ce françois comme étant un
quadragénaire célibataire est quelqu'un
qui
c'est un prof de fac qui est célibataire
endurci et qui en fait puise son vivier
de conquête dans ces étudiantes
d'ailleurs on nous présente ce milieu
universitaire comme un petit peu voilà
comme ça c'est à dire tout le monde
prend
des des amantes dans les études parmi
ces étudiantes je suis pas sûr que ce
soit une réalité
concrète ou une description que les
profs de fac et apprécierait met donc au
la ce se françois est un espèce de bobos
parisiens complètement désabusé et qui
voilà qui qui cherchent des conquêtes
qui a à ce moment là en mai 2022 une
une
une amante qui est une de ses étudiantes
un petit peu pérennes qui s'appelle
myriam qui est juive et elle et sa
famille devant le contexte un petit peu
tendu qu'augure l'élection de bel abbès
vont partir en israël donc il va se
retrouver sans sens copine régulière à
ce moment là donc
il se trouve que et bien tous les partis
d'abord le parti socialiste puis le
centre et la droite vont rallier bel
abbès est donc bien le rôle de
rassemblement national enfin le front
national à l'époque et bien va va se
retrouver seul contre bel abbès et cdma
baisse qui l'a gagné et françois bayrou
va devenir premier ministre de ben laden
alors notre protagoniste françois lui
est totalement détaché de la politique
au début de l'ouvragé donc ce qui fait
que au lieu d'aller voter
au second tour eh bien il va de peur de
la guerre civile il va partir un
programme dans une maison de famille
et est donc à suivre tout ça de un peu
de l'extérieur d'ailleurs en se rendant
en province il va à un moment s'arrêter
sur une aire d'autoroute
il va découvrir un une station service
où il ya eu un braquage avec les
braqueurs qui sont morts et les gens qui
les tenanciers qui sont morts aussi et
tout ce qui va trouver à faire c'est
prendre un sandwich
donc une personnalité assez curieuse
également on va donc
à travers d'autres personnages qu'il va
rencontrer françois parmi ses collègues
on va prendre un petit peu également du
plus gros du contexte politique donc en
fin de compte cette ascension d'un
président musulman se fait aussi avec
détention d'un point de vue identitaire
on apprend qu'à notamment des
groupuscules identitaires qui sont quand
même assez crispé qui sont qui cherche à
accélérer à la venue d'une guerre civile
il y aura d'ailleurs des incidents lors
du deuxième tour qui devra être fait une
deuxième fois parce que des urnes vont
être volés donc il va falloir
recommencer un deuxième tour mais le
résultat est le même c'est bel abbès qui
passe à ce moment là donc notre
protagoniste rentrer sur paris et est
bien n'est plus président n'est plus
professeur à la sorbonne puisque dans le
programme de bel abbès il ya notamment
tout un volet culturel et blaine abbès a
décidé que seules les personnes qui
étaient musulmanes et bien pourrait
enseigner et comme françois à ce moment
là se fiche un petit peu de ces
paperasse administrative ait été un
petit peu en vadrouille et bien le délai
est passé et il est mis à la retraite
d'office comme comme d'autres de ses
collègues
ensuite on va avoir toute une partie où
est bien ce françois va être
complètement désoeuvrés puisqu'il a plus
de travail il n'a plus de compagnies non
plus et donc qu'il va errer entre
guillemets symboliquement c'est à dire
qu'il va aller aux [ __ ] enfin aux
escortes parce que c'est un bobo et
qu'il allait les moyens avec pas mal de
passages assez vulgaire dégradant dans
l'indre et forment des descriptions mais
ça je viendrai dans dans les remarques
sur l'écriture il va également ensuite
tenter de retrouver la foi en faisant un
séjour dans un couvent comme sont comme
son héros fin comme comme huysmans sûr
qu'il a fait sa thèse parce que huysmans
a retrouvé la foi en allant dans un
monastère alors pour lui du coup ça va
pas du tout ce passé pareil il n'ya pas
d'élimination n'y a pas de vision de
dieu et du coup il rentre sur paris
et à ce moment là donc le nouveau
dirigeant de la sorbonne qui
s'appellerait digger qui donc musulman
qui est même un islamiste clairement et
qui est un ancien identitaire d'ailleurs
est bien là proches et voilà essaie de
le convaincre de reprendre sa place à la
sorbonne et donc essaie de le convertir
à l'islam et donc on a toute une partie
de dialogue et de lectures
conseillées par ready guère que fait
notre notre protagoniste et
protagonistes qui en fin de compte fini
dans les derniers chapitres et bien par
se rallier à islam il finit par se
convertir et donc ainsi eh bien il peut
retrouver sa fonction de professeur
alors il se rallie non pas par parfois
mais pour bien sûr des questions de
position sociale retrouver un emploi et
puis surtout ce qui est mis en avant
c'est cette question de l'accès à la
chair fraîche puisque pendant tous les
ouvrages on croise des musulmans y
compris rigueur qui ont plusieurs femmes
et
des femmes souvent jeunes ce que de
trois fois on voit des musulmans qui
sont mariés à des jeunes filles de 15 16
ans
et donc le livre se finit comme ça avec
une conversion sur l'islam et une
réintégration dans les sphères
universitaires et quelque part françois
trouve le bonheur grâce à une religion
qui lui permet bien d'avoir plusieurs
femmes et de la chair fraîche
donc voilà pour le résumé du livre alors
tout d'abord quelques remarques sur sur
l'écriture c'est un livre qui a été
écrit à la première personne donc qui
souffre des problèmes un petit peu
récurrent à ce genre d'écriture c'est à
dire que pour avoir des informations sur
le monde extérieur notre personnage doit
soit regarder la télé lire la presse ou
bien avoir des des personnages qui vont
nous présenter un peu là la situation et
c'est ce qui se passe dans toute la
première partie du livre c'est à dire
qu'il va rencontrer successivement des
collègues qui vont lui donner des
informations il va rencontrer un jeune
collègue universitaire qui est un ancien
ancien leader identitaire qui va lui
expliquer les tenants et aboutissants
des tensions ethniques etc
il a également une collègue et dont le
mari est directeur de bureau à la dg
ainsi donc on renseignement qui va aussi
lui apporter des éléments et nous
apporter des éléments de compréhension
sur sur la situation
et
du coup dans ce genre de récit à la
première personne ce genre de méthode
fait toujours un petit peu artificielle
et là je trouve que ça ne pouvait le bec
ne
déroge pas à la règle quelque part on a
l'impression pour reprendre à parler
avec les jeux vidéo d'avoir des pnj un
peu mal écrits qui viennent juste de
nous donner du background et
malheureusement c'est un peu
l'impression que ça donne puisque en
dehors de ces moments où il nous apporte
du contexte ces personnages mais ensuite
n'apparaissent pas réellement quand ils
ont vraiment une fonction purement
utilitaire pour nous décrire le le réel
des ouvrages
donc ça c'est toujours un peu les
limites de l'écriture la première
personne
autre question sur sur l'écriture tout
le tout le monde nouveaux ouvrages donc
on à françois don qui est caractérisée
par deux dimensions principales il est
prof de fac est spécialisé sur
joris karl huysmans ou car le jury celui
ce mensonge ne sais plus
et il est à la recherche de chair
fraîche ce sont vraiment les deux
dimensions un petit peu opposés du
bonhomme c'est un côté très intellectuel
il ya un autre très très basique très
animale et les scènes de sexe sont
décrits de façon très crue et son cru
mais d'un point
en fait sont très dégradantes je trouve
pour pour les femmes là dessus je
rejoins complètement les polémiques sur
la misogynie de houellebecq c'est à dire
que c'est pas juste la description
pour montrer que le mec chercheurs
frêche c'est que c'est vraiment c'est un
côté vulgaire quoi fin il prononce le
mot chatte 4,5 fois enfin il ya un
moment est ce que je trouve déplaisant
dans ça alors personnellement je suis un
charretier dans la vie quotidienne ne
soit pas là l'écran mais les jurés ou la
vulgarité mais j'aime pas forcément mais
là je trouve que dans cet ouvrage sa
pause ça pose question parce que cette
vulgarité
qui est vraiment je trouve rabaisse
uniquement la femme pour le coup qui est
vraiment vu comme un bout de viande de a
à z dans le bouquin ce que françois
cherche c'est pas les sentiments c'est
vraiment un
la chatte la chatte pour reprendre un
terme de l'ouvragé
ça me fait penser quelque part à cette
fascination qu'a l'art contemporain pour
le pipi caca popo vous savez leurs
contemporains qui est très axée autour
de trucs un peu
tabou entre guillemets dans notre
société et qu'ils tuaient transgressif
c'est à dire qu' il va mal traité notre
morale commune la bienséance etc mais
c'est une transgression qui est là pour
choquer le bourgeois qui est aussi la
cible de cette culture de cet art et qui
bourgeois qui justement m cette
transgression ce côté transgressif parce
que il ya un peu l'impression de
s'encanailler gratuitement et sans pour
autant qu'il y ait derrière de discours
politique qui remettrait en cause la sa
position sociale toujours le côté un
petit peu un petit peu idiot un petit
peu
vide de sens de ce cette transgression
dans l'art contemporain est quelque part
eh bien j'ai l'impression d'avoir un
petit peu la même chose dans ces
passages un petit peu vulgaire de
houellebecq c'est à dire c'est des
passages qui vont un petit peu aguicher
son lectorat bobos qui cherchent un
petit peu du des sensations mais sans
sans pour autant qu on aille jusqu à
tenir des propos qui pourraient voilà
remettre en cause quoi que ce soit dans
les dents là dans les strates sociales
ou quoi que ce soit donc ce côté
vulgaire je pense que c'est en partie
marketing pour justement donné le petit
frisson là du côté décadent transgressif
à son son lectorat on a le lectorat
composé envie de dire et d'un autre côté
effectivement il ya toujours cette
question est ce que françois quelque
part le personnage que ce n'est pas
aussi une partie de houellebecq est ce
que houellebecq créer un personnage 100%
de fiction ou est ce qu'il est vraiment
misogyne et franchement s'il s'ils
pensent serait-ce que 50 % de ce qu'elle
écrit dans le bouquin c'est voilà
humainement c'est pas quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire quoi enfin au delà du
côté
les femmes sont juste des bouts de
viande
c'est des bouts de viande et ses bo bun
qui fait la cuisine c'est vraiment ça
c'est pas vraiment une image très
glorieuse de la femme donc s'ils ne
serait-ce que 50% et pensé par
houellebecq on est vraiment chez
quelqu'un de humainement assez minable
honnêtement je suis incapable de vous
dire
ce qu'il en est si le si le pense ou non
j'ai pas lu assez digne de lui les
polémiques médiatiques sur la question
sont ce qu'elles sont
houellebecq nous dit que soumission est
une satire donc bon on peut considérer
que tu ne pense pas la même chose que
ses personnages
néanmoins après l'écouté d'un seul de
ses livres je suis incapable de vous
dire c'est le pense ou non et j'espère
que non donc voilà pour ce qui est du
de la forme maintenant venons en à la
question politique alors bon et à la
question de la misogynie mais du coup la
gêne d'aborder alors passons à la
question de l'islamophobie supposée du
livre alors l'islam qui a dépeint dans
soumission est un islam tout à fait
tout à fait réaliste c'est à dire que
c'est l'islam qui accourent globalement
dans les sociétés un petit peu
traditionnelle ou archaïque c'est à dire
oui société patriarcale
polygames ou le temporel et spirituel le
politique et le religieux ne sont pas
séparés et enfin clairement sur ce côté
là on n'a pas un islam fantasmé où il
serait vrai même caricature tel
l'afghanistan on est vraiment sur
quelque chose qui peut tout à fait avoir
cours dans d'autres pays ou même chez
nous là où le regard républicains ne va
plus
pour ce qui est des descriptions on
n'est pas non plus dans une forme de
mépris affiché pour l'islam pas du tout
certain n'est pas sur des termes
péjoratifs pour pour cette religion
comme on peut l'être pour les femmes par
exemple et même au contraire on sent une
forme de respect pour cette pour cette
religion un côté où elle à préserver un
certain mode de vie
à la cellule familiale ce genre de chose
que n'a pu notre monde moderne puisque
toute une partie des
ouvrages de houellebecq d'après ce que
j'en ai compris portent sur la critique
en fait de notre monde moderne et ce
monde qui voudraient faire le bonheur de
chacun mais qui en fin de compte ne fait
que le malheur de l'individu qui est
livré à lui-même effectivement voilà
qu'on a ce personnage françois qui qui a
certes une réussite sociale mais qui va
qui est le seul qui n'a pas fondé de
famille etc c'est un petit peu ça
et sur ce côté critique de la société
moderne et bien l'islam sert justement à
mettre face à face notre société
individualiste où on est censé être
épanoui libre et s'est
émancipé et l'autre côté la société
traditionnelle qui est certes
extrêmement contraignante il faut être
mariés il ya un code des contraintes
sociales plus importante que de nos
sociétés modernes mais qui en
contrepartie offre sans qu'on ait à
combattre entre guillemets et bien le
bonheur simple d'une vie de famille on
va vous trouver une femme puisque 30 des
ouvrages les universitaires que
convertit on leur trouve une femme parmi
les étudiantes directement c'est le
cadeau bonus
et donc je pense pas que ce soit un
livre qui soit islamophobe du tout
simplement l'islam qui est une religion
qu'on a aujourd'hui chez nous sert à
mettre en exergue les balles et les
travers aussi de notre société moderne
à nous et fatalement ma montre ce qu'est
une société traditionnelle mais c'est
l'islam mais je pense que ce serait à
peu près la même chose si c'était la
douche par exemple
donc livre islamophobe je ne pense
absolument pas je pense plutôt que c'est
un livre qui est une critique du monde
moderne à l'aide d'une société
traditionnelle d'ailleurs françois avant
de se tourner de dépit vers l'islam se
tourner vers la société traditionnelle
européenne puisqu'il va faire comme son
héros huysmans il va essayer de faire sa
retraite monastique
voyez trouvé trouvé dieu il cherche
aussi quelque part une femme comme comme
les décrit glissement sur ce que ce
qu'il appelle une femme pot-au-feu c'est
à dire une bonne ménagère qui comble son
mari femme un peu
serviable voir cyril et c'est uniquement
de dépit parce qu'ils trouvent pas
l'élimination chrétienne dans ce
monastère qu'il va se tourner vers une
autre tradition que la tradition
européenne
donc alors cette critique du coût de la
modernité
pourrait être intéressante
personnellement ça m'intéresse toujours
mais je trouve que
toute cette partie critique de notre
société moderne et de
l'individu isolé
du coup entre en confrontation quand
même frontale avec le rapport que
françois avec les femmes c'est à dire
que millénaire un rapport très moderne
entre guillemets à l'autre et à la gente
féminine c'est à dire un produit de
consommation comme un autre il ya
individualiste c'est son plaisir à lui
qui compte et les autres sont là pour
pour l'assouvir et quand il se tourne
vers l'islam c'est pour combler ce désir
basique et très moderne de consumérisme
de la chaire qui est qu il se convertit
en fin de compte il passe pas d'une
relation de la femme qui a un goût de
bifteck ah voilà relation d'une femme
qui serait
les gains sont son équivalent qu'il faut
qu'ils s'épanouissent etc non il va
parce que ces dates chair fraîche et des
personnes qui sont capables de le faire
des petits plats très clair non et donc
je trouve que toute la critique de notre
modernité ton d'un petit peu à l'eau
avec tout ce côté
vulgarité misogyne parce que ben si
c'est ça être conservateur quelque part
c'est ça c'est pas de l'orie ouvriers il
nous présente quelqu'un qui va se
tourner vers le conservatisme mais
uniquement pour des questions de
satisfaction personnelle assez bassement
matérielles et donc ça ne donne pas non
plus très envie quelque part de se
tourner vers cette société
traditionnelle face au néant affectif
que qu il nous dépeint dans notre
société moderne en fin de compte que le
livre montre c'est que un connard reste
un connard qui soit dans une société
moderne sociétés traditionnelles et
qu'il va choisir l'une ou l'autre en
fonction de ce qui les arrange par
rapport à son plaisir immédiat et à son
consumérisme donc c'est une critique
delà de notre modernité mais quelque
part ce n'est pas vraiment une critique
conservatrice parce qu'on aurait pu
l'espérer dans ce cas là c'était une
critique réellement conservatrice et
bien que le côté
le côté valeurs traditionnelles de
l'islam ou de toute autre religion
laissez-lui également pas que le côté
matériel
donc voilà ça c'est un petit peu dommage
également pour revenir sur la question
de l'islam
clairement ce dans cet ouvrage est un
moment donc françois entre en contact
avec rigueur donc l ancien identitaire
qui est islamiste maintenant et qui est
dirigeant de la sorbonne une fois le
président élu donc ce serait digger est
un peu un intellectuel il a écrit des
brochures des ouvrages sur voilà
pourquoi l'islam pourquoi se convertir
et clairement un pas mal des arguments
qui sont fournis dans le livre sont des
arguments qu'on peut entendre qu'on peut
trouver sur internet ou même moi j'ai
déjà entendu de la bouche des gens un
petit peu musulmans rigoriste donc là
non plus on n'est pas
pour ceux qui croiraient que les
arguments qui peuvent être déployées
dans le livre quand on parle du point de
vue des musulmans croient que c'est sa
mob non pas du tout enfin c'est que moi
j'aimerais manger bien entendu ce type
d'argument et enfin le monde est trop
compliqué pour qu'il était créée par
hasard ce genre de choses c'est
typiquement ce qu'on retrouve dans les
livres créationnistes et extrémiste au
sens large
donc voilà je pense que ce n'est pas un
livre qui est islamophobe très
clairement c'est un livre qui montre au
contraire que
houellebecq comprends c'est ce qu'est
l'islam est ce qu est une société
islamique sur la question de la
misogynie de houellebecq ouais
honnêtement je me pose des questions je
pense qu'il ya une part de réalité il
faudrait une part de houellebecq dans
dans françois
pour ce qui est
du livre en lui-même faut qu'il le lire
donc je vous avouerai que
personnellement j'ai c'est pas du tout
mon genre de bouquin j'ai vraiment
galéré à écouter écouter la fin sur le
côté
le côté
vulgarité rejoint un autre côté qui est
côté complètement
sociaux pratique du personnage principal
qui fait que c'est un personnage qui est
extrêmement désagréable à suivre et
quand il est plus question que de nuit
et qu'on a plus de contexte politique à
découvrir le
l' écoute a été laborieuse honnêtement
si j'avais lu à lire le livre j'aurais
peut-être abandonné tout simplement
parce que au delà du côté ils voient les
femmes comme des bouts de viande on a
aussi pas mal de signes qui montrent
qu'on est soi face à quelqu'un qui a une
dépression majeure soit qui est qui et
sociopathe dire qu'il se fout de tout
ses parents meurent il s'en fiche un
moment donc il dans une supérette tout
le monde est mort tout ce qu'ils
trouvent à faire c'est se prendre le
sandwich il n'appelle pas les flics ni
rien enfin et il ya plein de d'éléments
comme ça qui montre que le personnage se
fout totalement de l'autre alors ça peut
être un personnage écrit pour montrer à
la vacuité notre monde etc mais du coup
ça le rend extrêmement désagréable c'est
quelqu'un on peut passer attaché cinq
minutes
c'est difficile d'entrer en empathie
avec lui parce que c'est quand même un
espèce de bobo universitaire qui tape
sur un auteur que tout le monde a oublié
donc c'est là on n'entre pas en
résonance avec lui ça parle pas
il est désagréable donc du coup voilà ce
livre j'ai vraiment eu du film du mal à
elle finir et du coup je pense pas qu'il
soit à lire uniquement pour sa critique
de la modernité parce que c'est quelque
part une critique qui
qui n'est qu'à moitié fait puisque on
critique certaine modernité mais quelque
part
l'homme moderne un triomphe à la fin
même qui quand il se convertit à l'islam
ce qui se convertit par intérêt et
uniquement
donc voilà un livre
clairement moi donc je ne suis pas le
public je peux pas en dire beaucoup plus
sans être désagréable nettement mais
clairement je pense un livre qui ne
mérite pas les polémiques
et qu'ils ont eue sur l'islam en tout
cas sur la misogynie oui mais pas sur
l'islam qui la lui quand il est sorti et
d'ailleurs je me pose la question est-ce
que s'il sortait aujourd'hui en 2022 on
aurait des polémiques
sur la question de l'islamophobie ou non
vu que voilà depuis parce qu'il est
quand même sortie elle était écrit avant
les attentats de 2015 puis avant
l'émergence de dèche maintenant on a un
petit peu plus au courant de ce qui est
capable de faire un islam ou une partie
de l'islam sur dans le sordide donc
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui serait il n'y
aurait pas cette polémique sur sur le
côté islamophobe alors que peut-être on
fera plus les polémiques sur le côté
misogyne anti féministes etc du coup je
me demande vraiment ce que ça donnerait
si forte aujourd'hui mais donc voilà un
livre que personnellement je n'ai pas
spécialement apprécié qui d'un point de
vue
politique a des éléments intéressants
mais qui malheureusement sont trop noyé
dans un espèce de personnages
désagréable nihiliste sociopathe même
par certains côtés et totalement
consumériste le fait que ce soit une
satire j'ai envie de dire n'excusent
n'excuse pas tout il ya un moment il
faut quand même que l'on trouve un peu
de plaisir à lire à lire un ouvrage
scapa ou à l'écouté ce qui est pas été
vraiment mon cas pour pour ce coup-ci
donc voilà pour ceux qui étaient de cet
avis sur soumission n'hésitez pas à
donner vos avis également commentaires
si vous aussi vous l'avez lu parce que
n'étant pas fan de houellebecq ou de ce
genre même douvres âge
très personnaliste ou d'existentialisme
je ne sais pas trop comment dire
vraiment j'ai du mal à juger ce genre de
choses
bref en tout cas cette vidéo est terminé
et si vous allez apprécier bien
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
et à partager est sûre ce jeudi à la
prochaine